zoom in all the way into today zoom in
zoom in zoom in zoom and zoom in until
it's so close keep going zoom and zoom
and zoom and zoom and zoom in that's the
most you can go okay so how scary does
that look not that bad
right if you look at that what does that
story say you're like Pat I mean listen
man what are you guys panicking it's
only 5.7 percent
okay I mean if we go a little bit back
keep going all the way like put your uh
put the thing on it no put the mouse on
The yeah keep going back when's the last
time it was 5.7 keep going back back
2008 coming down right there all right
what is that 2008 coming down okay so
2005.7 all right now in 2007 when it was
5.7 had we printed the amount of
trillions of dollars that we printed now
no no keep going back we were printing
houses six percent keep going back keep
going back seven percent keep going back
seven percent eight percent keep going
back nine percent keep going back keep
going back keep going back keep now zoom
in a little bit so everybody sees what
happens here okay now go all the way to
the top and what is that 18.37 and what
Jimmy Carter did is not one 100 at what
we're doing right now with the way we're
printing money so that right there folks
if you're listening that's the worst
case scenario
the worst case scenario is 18.37 which I
don't think we're going to get to the
worst case scenario but the best case
scenario is somewhere in the middle that
we can potentially get to that 5.7 could
hit 10.
just telling you it could don't be
surprised if it goes to eight to ten
percent maybe higher than that for like
a month or two and then all of a sudden
they start printing three trillion
dollars of money again to solve it and
it could get nasty so Dave Ramsey may be
right but there's this thing called data
and it looks like inventory is going up
and history of rates 5.7 right now is
still cheap and we're probably gonna hit
seven eight nine ten sometime in the
next six 12 24 months you know what's
interesting
um
I'd like to find out what they did what
the FED did what the presidents he did
during Carter during the late 80s when
Reagan came in early 80s uh what they
did to fight inflation like did what
what did they do to fight these interest
rates meaning like right now you talk
about quantitative easing they've done
all that now they're raised raising uh
interest rates Yeah by a quarter three
quarters of a percentage what did they
do that then and how long did it take to
settle down the economy this is before
my time you were probably in your late
teens 20s during at this time so maybe
you remember what they did economically
do you remember what they did yeah I did
my dad my dad had conversations with me
about it and um there's two things and
he used to say he didn't talk about
capitalism but he said listen Reagan is
going to expand the economy and when the
economy expands taxes are created and
they naturally
you know cure a lot of ills they build
jobs so the government doesn't have to
provide assistance they create expansion
and taxes for the government so the
government doesn't have to raise taxes
and Reagan came in and made a Reagan tax
cut and also drove expansionist policies
because he had to do he had to whip two
things at the same time it was Jimmy
Carter and this is one of the Great
Moments in presidential debates
um Jimmy Carter had assailed Gerald Ford
in 1976 that election saying you know Mr
Ford you know you um there's a misery
index on the American people you know
it's five percent interest rates and
it's six percent unemployment that's a
misery index of 11 or 12 whatever it was
four years later Reagan looked at him at
the presidential debate so Mr Carter I'd
like to remind you you invented the
misery index and then then it was up to
21. so he says congratulations you've
increased the misery index which you
defined but it was
reducing regulation of businesses
expansionist Economic Policy any cut
taxes and guess what happened people got
jobs people paid reasonable taxes with
those jobs the economy expanded and you
can take a look it went down as fast as
it went up and you know back then
there's a guy named David Stockman that
liberals used to refer to it as voodoo
economics trickle-down Theory but guess
what
history shows it worked so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
foreign